james desperate fabulous actor but i
think it's fair to say that
music was your first love it well it was
no i i sang
a lot as a child we were from quite a
musical family and you were in musicals
uh i was in musicals i mean the first
job i did was the um
i played the artful dodger people talk
of it still yeah yeah well people say
i'm still playing exactly the same role
uh no i played the art for dodger uh
when i was 13
uh and then did telly come calling
immediately well um
my my friends uh uh as a result wrote to
gloria hanford remember gloria
of course gloria hanford and groyer used
to do was was that the day end of kind
of um
uh news and magazine kind of television
programmes she was the graeme norton of
her day uh
she is she's the glory hollywood of now
and she is fantastic
yeah and um my friends had written to
her about unbeknownst to me saying that
they wanted to set up an australia
theater
and she did a live magazine show every
night and so i
knew nothing about this i was playing
rugby actually in colerain at school one
day
i was dragged off the pitch i was thrown
into a car by this director and my mates
we
were taken up to belfast went live on a
show
in our costumes from oliver that we put
on in the um
in the car on the way up and at the end
of the week we did a bit of a chat with
gloria about setting up an australian
theater we were
13. and at the end of it gloria said
well we've got a bit of time so
the boys are going to sing us out with
um there's no business like show
business which is not a song from oliver
so we stood behind gloria and she went
take it away and the other two couldn't
sing to save their lives
and we went uh there's no business like
show business like no business i know
this terrible awkward silence and groyer
just went oh well at least they're all
full of spunk
now when you're 13 when the 13th splunk
means one thing
and so i burst out laughing meanwhile my
mother and father were in korean
waiting for me to come home from rugby
for my tea so it was quite a rude
awakening to my tv
[Laughter]
[Music]
career
you